bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur tv fil 78 si vous nous rejoignez
bien sûr pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8
sociétés vous pouvez réagir sur le
twitter de l'émission hashtag 7,8
société le 27 octobre 2005 deux
adolescents mouret électrocutés à
clichy-sous-bois dans un transformateur
électrique où il s'était réfugié pour
échapper à un contrôle de police
un drame à l'origine de trois semaines
d'émeutes ou de révolte souvent les
points de vue jacques chirac alors
président de la république avait fait
une allocution télévisée avec un message
à destination des enfants des quartiers
populaires ont leur affirmant qu'elles
que soient vos origines vous êtes tous
des filles et fils de la république dix
ans après qu'en est il vraiment la
situation des quartiers populaires s'est
elle améliorée la politique de la ville
at elle réussi à réduire les inégalités
et les discriminations à favoriser la
mixité sociale
l'école de la république permet tel
toujours l'ascension sociale pour
répondre à ces questions
quatre invités autour de la table
maïmouna bas bonsoir vous êtes
sociologue spécialiste de questions gay
à la déscolarisation abdelhak kachouri
qu'on soit vous êtes conseiller général
et vice président de la région ile de
france en charge de la citoyenneté de la
politique de la ville et de la sécurité
morale charming
bonsoir vous êtes fondateur et
secrétaire général de l'association jury
citoyen si des citoyens vous nous en
direz un autre tout à l'heure et enfin
stéphane dumont chiron soir pour soi
vous êtes membre de trappes citoyens et
conseiller municipal d'opposition à
trappes
d'ailleurs j'ai oublié de le préciser
mourad charlie est également conseiller
municipal d'opposition à trappes à leur
première question assez simple diriez
vous que la situation dans les quartiers
populaires depuis 2005 s'est plutôt
améliorée
ou est-ce que les choses
se sont dégradés en dix ans bonsoir je
suis pas conseiller général et
vice-président du conseil régional
conseiller général de dole alpes en
voilà et conseiller municipal à neuilly
sur marne
non moi je pense que la situation à
l'évidence s'est quelque peu améliorée
si on voit ça sous l'angle de la
rénovation urbaine et du changement
urbain des quartiers populaires dans
lequel se concentre un maximum de
difficultés économiques et sociales
après l'évidence quand on voit
l'actualité quotidienne d'un certain
nombre de territoires franciliens
on a quand même beaucoup de chemin à
faire et donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui
malgré les moyens conséquents que les
différents gouvernements
vous avez cité jacques chirac tout à
l'heure je me souviens de cette
déclaration que l'ancien président de la
république a pu faire les spectateurs en
direction des fils et des filles de la
république j'aime bien cette expression
parce que c'est comme ça que je les
considère aussi il ya des choses qui ont
été faites mais on rame encore sur les
questions d'accès à l'emploi d'accès à
la formation d'accès à l'apprentissage
d'accès au logement d'accès aux soins et
cetera et cetera donc sur le plan de la
rénovation au peigne on peut considérer
que les choses changent
sur le plan social sur le plan
économique complet c'est plus compliqué
parce que le problème est très compliqué
à gérer
brad charlie maintenant qu'il est
important de préciser et de souligner
que de prime abord on peut pas extraire
la situation des habitants des quartiers
populaires de celle de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens je considère qu en effet que
depuis 2007 2008 la dernière crise
financière
on assiste à une dégradation accélérée
l'ensemble de la situation d'ensemble de
concitoyens conçoit fonctionnaires
classes moyennes salariées du privé ou
populations rurales
je crois qu'effectivement aujourd'hui on
peut pas partager le même constat à
savoir qu'effectivement il ya une
amélioration de la situation dossiers de
nos concitoyens alors face à cette
situation de crise
malheureusement on peut que déplorer que
certains responsables politiques ou
discours politiques ont choisi de
diviser et d'opposer les français
pour certains la situation actuelle
serait le fait d'une d'un statut
privilégié des fonctionnaires par
exemple ou des salariés du privé qui
serait trop protégée par une législation
du travail qu on met en cause
aujourd'hui
ou encore que le modèle social français
est trop et trop favorable à cette
situation on peut que déplorer aussi la
posture de certains analystes ou
commentateurs ou intellectuels français
qui en endossant la posture de prophètes
de malheur
nous explique qu'effectivement il y à
une situation de déclin ou voir le
promettre carrément le chaos de la
société française sur sur des critères
ou sur une grille de lecture beaucoup
sur les plateaux télé campent les taux
c'est déplorable parce qu'effectivement
c'est révélateur d'une situation qui est
pour moi est dramatique et s'est dégradé
depuis depuis une dizaine d'années voilà
bah moi je voulais exprimer un petit peu
sur leur faim dans le domaine scolaire
et celui de l'emploi ou moi je me rends
pas j'ai pas l'impression cadre des
évolutions il ya toujours autant de
jeunes qui sortent du système sans
qualification les cent cinquante mille
jeunes qui sortent du système scolaire
sans qualification c'est une réalité
dix ans plus tard et dans l'accès à
l'emploi clairement
c'est toujours c'est beaucoup les mêmes
qui n'arrivent pas à trouver un emploi
et en général c'est aussi lié à ce
manque de qualification et je vous
rejoins quand vous dites qu'il ya que
l'anru est passée par là effectivement
il à manqué la phase de rénovation
urbaine effectivement est passée par là
clairement les quartiers ont changé de
11 changer le visage seulement la
résidentialisation mettre des coups de
peinture sur sur des bâtiments ça suffit
pas quoi ça suffit pas et ça a même créé
en tout cas sûre dans le domaine
scolaire ça a créé des difficultés aussi
parce que des quartiers il ya eu des
mouvements de population des fois subi
pour certaines pour certaines familles
et ça aussi un petit peu déstabilisé les
parcours scolaires moi il m'est arrivé
de rencontrer dans le cadre de mes
recherches des familles donc à qui on a
demandé de changer de quartier donc des
familles qui étaient implantés dans ces
quartiers là depuis un certain nombre
d'années et qui avait également créé
quelque chose avec l'équipe enseignante
qui sont retrouvés dans des dans des
écoles n'ont connu et ça c'est vrai que
ça pose un souci aussi parce que du coup
ce sont des familles qui avaient créé
quelque chose avec avec l'institution
écoles et qui avait créé quelque chose
avec les équipes éducatives
sa seule la rupture et ça ça a été une
réelle rupture s'était fait doucher pour
finir ce premier tour de table
alors c'est une question qui est quand
même assez complexe parce que je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez récemment il
ya deux informations qui sont à parle
d'une part une information qui explique
que les inégalités régresse mme d
égalité province en france et lui de
l'autre la pauvreté progresse donc des
choses qui paraissent assez
contradictoire est effectivement dans
les banlieues on est confronté à trappes
notamment à des problèmes de ce type là
avec d'un côté comme vous l'expliqué
très bien des personnes parlent le fait
de la rénovation urbaine de classes
moyennes inférieures aux moyennes qui
viennent s'installer dans les
copropriétés
donc il rehausse le niveau
sociale ou économique d'une ville et
d'un côté des quartiers hlm et qui reste
dans un état difficultés sociales
traitent très importante donc on peut
pas dire de en bloc que ça progresser ou
sa règle et c'est très nuancée à mon
avis en fonction des villes des
quartiers les politiques qui ont été
menées alors un deuxième conseil
interministériel à l'égalité et à la
citoyenneté s'est tenue le 26 octobre
dernier donc aux mureaux plusieurs
propositions sur la table lutte contre
la ségrégation pour reprendre le terme
ou l'apartheid pour reprendre le terme
de manuel valls le premier ministre un
lutte contre la discrimination la
relation police habitant la lutte contre
la radicalisation
alors comment vous voyez-vous toutes ces
propositions qui sont mis sur la table
et on a l'impression aussi que c'est des
propositions qu'on écoute qu'on entend à
chaque fois à chaque fois qu'il ya une
proposition dit lutte contre les
discriminations égalité des chances et
quels sont les résultats aujourd'hui en
2015 est ce qu'il ya des choses qui vont
marcher ou pas moi sans lui dire
enfin ça suffit enfin les paroles on les
a ce sont les mêmes qui reviennent
depuis depuis dix ans donc de nos
politiques
elles sont louables mais un moment donné
passons aux actes quoi quand moi
j'entends toutes ces propositions et qui
à côté je vois qu'il ya de moins en
moins du vin dans les quartiers qui a
moins de sens - d'humains même dans les
villages parce qu'on parle pas que des
quartiers il ya beaucoup de de ruralité
aussi enfin beaucoup de territoires qui
sont dans les territoires ruraux qui ont
les mêmes difficultés
maintenant il faut agir quoi ça suffit
quads et les discours quoi parce qu'on
connaît on la problématique elle et elle
est posée maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
fait quoi bien évidemment c'est normal
de l'acte avec l'âge nourrisson das
toujours pas fait au hasard
d'abord non mais c'est pas c'est
toujours bon de rappeler aux décideurs
politiques quels qu'ils soient locaux
départementaux régionaux nationaux
européens et plus largement encore au
plan international qu'ils ont des
responsabilités qu'ils doivent traduire
les engagements qu'ils prennent moi j'ai
vous aura pas échappé
voter pour françois hollande en 2012 sur
un certain nombre d'engagements qu'il a
pris à l'endroit notamment des quartiers
populaires donc je vais vous faire
l'économie de ce que je pense sur le
droit de vote des étrangers
je suis très déçu la manière avec
laquelle on a repoussé cette mesure
extrêmement importante et cas vraiment
mobilisés pour le coup les trois quarts
des quartiers populaires mais quand même
quand vous dites chez un madame que
l'humain doit être doit être enfin le
renforcement humains dans les
territoires peu en grande partie
répondre aux carences le service public
dans les quartiers aux carences des
coûte d'un certain nombre de jeunes qui
aujourd'hui sont délaissés et qui
considèrent que la république recule moi
je suis de ceux qui pensent que dès lors
que la république recule dans les
territoires populaire ça laisse place à
des modes de réflexion à des modes de
comportements qui peuvent structure est
le pire qui peuvent structurer le pire
on est en ile-de-france moi je suis
chargé les questions de politique de la
ville de citoyenneté de sécurité du
contre les discriminations et sur un
certain nombre de territoires
moi je veux juste compléter mon propos
initial cher monsieur je n'ai pas dit
que l'anru règlerait tous je n'ai pas
dit que parce que on a refait des
quartiers
entier on a réglé le problème je dis
juste que l'anru doit être accompagnée
d'un renforcement de service public
deux travailleurs sociaux de professeurs
de fonctionnaires dans les hôpitaux de
fonctionnaires de police etc etc etc
et comme on est donc des moyens bien sûr
et bien sûr qu'il manque des moyens
je peux comprendre asie on entend
partout qu'il faut faire des jeux vous
le dis comme je le pense
ça suffit de faire des économies sur les
quartiers les plus fragiles ça suffit il
faut qu'on soit clair où on décide de
mettre les moyens de mettre le paquet
sur un certain nombre de territoires sur
le long terme et c'est palpable j'aime
bien cette expression de palpable
voilà et on palpe les voilà on peut
évaluer le bilan des engagements
comprend où on fait semblant et ça
marchera pas de toute façon ça marchera
pas et moi ça ne marchera pas et les
gens sont pas dupes
il ya un moment donné enfin on ne peut
pas prendre les femmes et les personnes
pour des idiots quoi on dans les
quartiers où ou même ailleurs fera le là
on sent qu'il commence à y avoir un gros
fossé entre le monde entre le politique
et la réalité des fins la réalité c'est
pour ça que nous ayons o'casey rançon le
taux d'amh incroyable dans la province
en pluie et l'europe lui est également
le repli
parce que c'est ça aussi un ccd gens qui
vont voter qui vont se replier sur
eux-mêmes et qu'ils vont voter pour les
extrêmes
c'est pire que l'abstention alors moi
j'aimerais juste rappeler aux uns et aux
autres que le recul que nous avons
aujourd'hui sur les quartiers ça date
pas de 2005 les émeutes effectivement de
2005 en cache d'autres qui les ont
précédés moi j'appartiens à la
génération de ceux qui ont connu
vénissieux les minguettes
j'habite en région lyonnaise elle voit
la voie en place et c'est des choses
qu'on a déjà connu malheureusement
et il en va de même pour les politiques
de la ville certains palaces le curseur
sur l'anru moi j'ai envie de dire que ça
fait 30 ans aujourd'hui la politique de
la ville depuis l'arrivée de l'une sert
à une certaine époque fracassantes et
j'ai envie d'y revenir avant l'heure
d'un monsieur tapie qui était venue en
grand pompe inauguré le ministère de la
politique de la ville et
au bout de 2 milliards qui ont été
dépensés j'ai envie de dire que le
compte n'y est pas ou le bilan est très
mince
effectivement des façades qui ont été
ravalées des des aménagements urbains
qui ont été faits comme ceux que je
considère comme un cache misère puisque
effectivement quand on regarde d'un peu
plus près souvent les gens de ces
territoires n'ont plus les moyens
d'habiter ces résidences qui ont été
effectivement rénover voire reconstruite
et j'en veux pour preuve effectivement
la dernière visite de délégations euros
qui prend le soin d'aller visiter
effectivement une portion de quartier
qui a été rénové voir effectivement un
quartier entièrement neufs qui évite
soigneusement d'aller voir ce quartier
de ses six musiciens ceux là même qui ne
peuvent pas habiter ces nouveaux
quartiers
donc oui des nouveaux quartiers de beaux
immeubles clinquant mais est-ce qu'on a
les moyens de payer les loyers qui sont
réévaluées à la hausse avec des gens qui
connaissent et qui sont frappés plus que
d'autre part par le chômage etc
donc il ya des faux semblants qu'il faut
savoir dénoncer et il faut pas se
laisser tromper effectivement part parce
qu'il est donné à voir d'abord qu'est-ce
que c'est l'histoire de la politique de
la ville la politique de la ville ça
commence dans les années 70 avec les
groupes d'action municipale une
revendication très clair il faut pas
faire d'économies d'un côté du social de
l'autre et c'est et une espèce de
synergies et ça ça a mis du temps à
arriver
effectivement dans les ministères à en
commençant par les sous le gouvernement
je crois ou en commencé à mettre en
place sous le gouvernement adopte salle
de balladur ou encre et les premiers
contrats de ville avec simone veil ou là
on essaye de créer une et c'est une
espèce de synthèse et puis on arrive à
l'anru et puis effectivement on arrive à
des résultats qui donnent le sentiment
d'une intervention plutôt technocratique
humaine avec deux groupes deux gros
blocs dans la politique de la ville
urbanisme qui parfois est vécue de façon
tragique parce que les gens qui habitent
depuis des lustres dans un quartier tout
à coup on leur bâtiment détruit on leur
demande d'aller habiter à chartres
amante ou à guyancourt bref des endroits
où ils n'ont absolument semble assez
d'accord pour dire que ces grands
ensembles wii était à détruire toute
façon un vive alors ça dépend parce que
voyez-vous par exemple 15 étages 16
étages avec presque sa dépendance à son
encontre parce qu'il y ait aussi ça
dépend parce que là aussi la réflexion
évolué monsieur qui le monsieur qui est
décédé il ya un début d'année qui était
sénateur et maire de clichy claude
dilain hui sa réflexion a évolué par
rapport à ça au départ ils étaient pour
raser cvo ensemble et et construire des
habitations nouvelles lui les blessés
dit non dans certains endroits il faut
maintenir le patrimoine le patrimoine
hlm et en parallèle on y avait une
notion la riante parallèle construire
d'autres bâtiments et de type
copropriété pour créer de la mixité
sociale
parce que dans une banlieue il n'y a pas
que des problèmes dans l'est dans les
rues dans l'est dans les logements
sociaux il ya aussi des problèmes dans
les copropriétés déco prix copropriété
pourquoi il ya des preuves parce que des
fois les gens qui viennent habiter en
banlieue qui viennent acheter en
banlieue c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les moyens ailleurs
donc on arrive à une peu plus à sa part
des fonds qu'ils achètent par défaut ce
soir là moi je suis un exemple typique
de cette lan acheteurs par des gens à un
acheteur par des fous à trappes
mais il voit là bas et puis après ils
n'ont pas écouté
alors qu'on va parler justement parce
que vous parliez de ce fossé de ce gap
qui se crée entre justement la politique
et les habitants alors une des mesures
proposées par le gouvernement et par
manuel valls et la nomination de
délégués du gouvernement qui
travailleront en lien avec le préfet et
le maire la ville de trappes fera partie
des villes pilotes
on écoute manuel valls qui explique
justement le rôle de ces futurs délégués
il aura l'autonomie nécessaire notamment
budgétaires pour mobiliser les
ressources du territoire administration
comme association afin de bâtir de
manière réactive et créative des
solutions sur mesure
pour obtenir des résultats tangibles
pour les habitants une réaction en
plateau j'ai pas tout compris que ce
délégué qu'est-ce qui va je pensais
qu'il y avait déjà des délégués du
préfet qui existait et qui servait de
lien entre les villes et les et la
préfecture et ensuite avec le
gouvernement par mois ce serait se
serait ce serait comme on dirait ge
incohérent vous dire que tous moyens
humains supplémentaires ne serait pas
bon à prendre
premier ministre a fait ces annonces la
de ce que j'ai compris moi en tout cas
c'est que ce délégué la s'assurerait de
la bonne traduction des orientations du
gouvernement il ya le délégué du préfet
qui lui a une mission un petit peu plus
globale etc et le lien aux côtés des
entreprises des collectivités des
associations etc
ce délégué là il serait chargé
exclusivement de traduire sur les
questions associative la politique du
gouvernement pourraient également gérer
il aurait un budget c'est ce qu'annonce
amoureuse associé ce cas là c'est moi
c'est ce que j'ai entendu de la bouche
du premier ministre donc supplémentaires
supplémentaires enfin elle a dit oui
c'est parce qu'il a dit voilà c'est un
délégué du préfet c'est nfl était
optimiste samedi
je suis très optimiste de ministres a
nommé délégué du gouvernement sur huit
sites pilotes pour faire émerger de
nouvelles méthodes de travail local ok
mais samedi ça signifie quoi ça
concrètement oui ça signifie quoi mon
coach parle du main je parle des
éducateurs supplémentaires
et alors que je suis pas forcément pour
la politique du chiffre
comment je suis plus pour la qualité
mais en attendant la présence humaine ce
type en tout cas de présence humaine
quand on parle d'éducateurs et cetera il
ya maintenant moins en moins ces dix
dernières années elle a de moins en
moins les associations
je veux dire elles se réduisent comme
peau de chagrin elles sont on leur à
sucre est aussi beaucoup beaucoup
énormément de subventions ne serait ce
que par rapport à la carte scolaire
enfin la lah à la carte donc des des
zones prioritaires enfin l'année
dernière la perrière a été de la
verrière qui est quand même une commune
peut pas dire que ce soit qui ont des
fleurs qui roulent sur l'or de quartier
a perdu dont des quartiers qui étaient
en des quartiers dits en mode et de
l'acier a priori exactement d'éducation
prioritaire si moi je vais dire ça ça
n'a pas de sens croit donc non je peins
je trouve un avoir un préfet
supplémentaire ou un délégué je sais pas
comment on peut donner c'est pas ça dont
on a besoin
qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin après voilà
rapidement pour assurer ses missions
avoir les capacités qu'il aura les
capacités de décision
les moyens qu'il aura si ça se trouve il
aura beaucoup de moyens et qui viendra
compléter l'action du préfet et ses
moyens il reste attendons de voir ce qui
va faire attendre donc vous aspirez
revers en tout cas je pense que il y a
il ya sur les noms les quartiers il ya
vraiment des gens qui ont beaucoup
beaucoup
enfin qui ont des choses à faire qui ont
des choses à proposer sont également des
propositions et attendons de voir aller
s'entraîner ce sont bien elles sont bien
ministre il a mis ce fait ça comme ça
juste pour réaliser les rails fois là
bas cela il devrait il faut y aller là
c'était d'accord alors un délégué pour
traduire la politique du gouvernement
je viens moi je préférerais qu'on
traduise le quotidien et le besoin dé la
population dans les villes populaires
bon c'est effectivement encore une
mesure de type technocratique et ça me
rappelle la réflexion d'un délégué du
préfet en seine-saint-denis disais mais
on nous demande de mettre en place des
comités citoyens
franchement je suis dit
enfin c'est mais qui parle je suis
délégué du préfet je ne me sens pas
forcément très légitime pour remettre ça
en place c'est peut-être plus aux
municipalités aux médecins aux
associations été lancée voilà exactement
aux associations ils sont pas appliquées
partout on attrape ça n'a pas été mieux
de mettre ça en place
en fait je pense que le maître mot de la
politique de la ville c'est émancipation
émancipation par l'école émancipation
par des initiatives immensee passion par
l'emploi et donc on n'a pas compris ça
on n'arrivera pas à grand chose dans le
cas de la pluie qui doivent y carrément
ses patients par l'école worrack charlie
et puis après mais là bas puisque c'est
sa spécialité
est ce que c'est encore possible
actuellement notamment dans les villes
comme enfin dans les villes quartiers
populaires mois sur cette annonce j'ai
envie de dire chiche et prendre le
premier ministre au mot et j'attends de
rencontrer au delà de voir ce que ça va
donner j'entends de rejet invite
monsieur le délégué ou c'est pour les
mois à venir apportera pas sur tout à
fait normal ou madame madame monsieur
effectivement de venir nous rencontrer
et devoir effectivement dans quelle
mesure on peut on peut faire vivre ce
dispositif qui j'espère aboutir à
quelque chose enfin de concret et qui
nous permettra d'aborder appréhender les
problématiques de fond on a évoqué les
aspects de forme est effectivement sur
le fond nous sommes en attente et avec
des grand besoin dont il est un des
aspects une piste je propose une
monsieur madame le délégué d'envisager
effectivement de faire avec les
habitants et avec les citoyens et donc
ne vous reposez notamment réussi à
pratiquer dans cette discussion on peut
construire envisagé réfléchir ensemble
et faire émerger des solutions concrètes
pourquoi pas mais mona bas sur
l'émancipation comme disait stéphane
démouchy par l'école est ce que c'est
encore possible dans ces quartiers on a
l'impression que tout ce que veulent les
parents où la majorité des parents je
sais pas de ville dans des quartiers
populaires c'est que leurs enfants
sortent de cette villa et dont une
écosse tout simple bien sûr et
moi en tout cas je crois encore à
l'école républicaine je pense qu'elle
souffre de beaucoup de mots mais j'y
crois dur comme fer et je pense que oui
l'école peut nous sortir d'une de la
misère incomplète enfin clairement
maintenant l'école souffre de beaucoup
de mots et il faut valoriser aussi des
initiatives ici et là pour justement
faire en sorte que les gamins ils
trouvent aussi leur compte et je rejoins
comme vous dites que les parents il n'y
a pas de parents démissionnaires comme
on a pu entendre ici et là ou dans les
journaux il ya des parents dépassés
il ya des parents oui dépassés par la
situation etc
mais il n'y a pas de parents qui ne
souhaite pas la réussite de 2 de son
enfant donc on en revient toujours à
cette à cette notion donc d'humains
parce que face à un gamin qui est de
crocheur face à des parents qui sont
dépassés des voix il suffit pas grande
chose il faut et il suffit pas de
millions il suffit simplement de
quelqu'un à côté donc de ses parents et
de ses enfants pour leur dire c'est
possible personnes accrochez-vous quoi
et ça je veux dire que ce qui est bien
c'est ce qui manque de pot c'est ce qui
manque
dernière question pourra terminer cette
annexion totalement son propos il ya pas
de parents démissionnaires il ya des
parents dépassés et sa peau vraiment
l'avoir en tête ce qu'on a trop tendance
à accabler les parents
on a trop tendance à pointer du doigt
des parents qui sont déjà au bout du
rouleau
parce que voilà il faut assurer une
activité professionnelle etc
c'est déjà extrêmement compliqué si en
plus subir les décideurs politiques
pointent du doigt et je les ai en tête
nos adversaires politiques qui explique
que de toute façon ce sont des
démissionnaires les gamins sont livrés à
eux mêmes ces deux forces ont dû se sont
dépassés ou vous dire franchement ces
gens de gauche qui a réparé sa eu eux
sont démissionnaires hélas on n'y croit
plus à l'arrêt
euny conserver judas pouvoir là je n'y
crois plus peut-être pour terminer voir
interne et pour ceux qui les croient
plus à la république à ce qu'il ya une
alternative on voit beaucoup de
collectifs citoyens qui se monte
actuellement dix ans que les jeunes
beaucoup de jeunes ou en tout cas d'
habitants de ces quartiers ne croient
plus en la politique aura pu parti
socialiste un républicain même front de
gauche ou autres autres partis est-ce
que c'est peut-être moi je fais partie
de ceux qui effectivement pense
aujourd'hui que nos vieilles démocraties
ont besoin de trouver un nouveau souffle
on a connu en face sur l'autre rive de
la méditerranée des sociétés des nations
des peuples qui se cherche une nouvelle
voie à travers la démocratie et moi je
pense qu'effectivement nous n'échappons
pas à la règle qui consiste à
questionner et à repenser nos
démocraties parce qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui ça ne fonctionne plus le
seul modèle de la représentation
aujourd'hui a montré ses limites on voit
le fossé qui se creuse entre un
personnel politique qui s'éloigne aussi
de plus en plus des véritables réalité
des considérations et des citoyens et
des citoyennes qui sont en demande
aujourd'hui de pouvoir agir et interagir
et prendre part aussi à l'effort pour
effectivement relancer l'espoir au sein
de au sein de parmi nos concitoyens mais
oui rapidement maillon la barre une note
d'espoir ce serait exactement ça serait
vraiment dommage de clore le débat en
soulignant pas que tous ces quartiers
regorge de talents vraiment il ya des
pépites dans ces quartiers là et ça
c'est dommage de ne pas en profiter ce
serait dommage de ne pas en profiter
ce serait dommage que la société n'en
profite pas ce serait dommage que
l'économie
n'en profite pas et la question scolaire
elle est intimement liés la question de
l'emploi par hbo est intimement liée à
la question scolaire
donc si on veut lutter contre le chômage
des jeunes il faut aussi traiter les
phénomènes qui mène à la déscolarisation
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à ce débat n'hésitez pas débat
très intéressant merci encore n'hésitez
pas à réagir sur le twitter de
l'émission hashtag 7,8 société la
semaine prochaine vous retrouvez
wilfried richy pour un 7 8 politique
et oui élections régionales obligent à
bientôt